thank you
[Music]
what's your last name wrong skull's name
yeah oh dang it's made up it's uh my mom
and my dad's last name put together it's
made up yeah like from a legal point of
view yeah someone birth certificate and
everything my social security card
everything oh [ __ ] that's where the
origin come from
like wow German descent or something
sounds like a Dutch name it's like
Vietnamese and [ __ ] and white and
white not even bad an eye dude sounds
Vietnamese to me that's what I said wait
are you part white I used to be why do
you used to be part white well like the
first I'm like 37 now so the first 30
years of my life I had a white grandpa
no but like genetically like yeah yeah
he was so how do you used to be part way
well because uh when I turned 30 I found
out he wasn't my blood grandpa oh no
[Music]
oh okay yeah we should talk about that
that's f'd up dude and then uh what was
it uh apparently everybody knew except
for me even my wife knew that I was like
wait what what was the point of telling
you that after 30 years maybe you just
never questioned it no nobody even
brought it up I thought so you just
thought he was your grandpa and you
thought your wife no but not you she I
guess she talked about it with my uh
sister Ron just never asked yeah yeah
also that yeah because who asked hey is
this my real girlfriend so for the
longest time you thought you were like a
quarter white yeah everybody thought I
was quick because I said it and I said
it was so much confidence because I
believed it you know yeah and then I was
like yeah and then they're like
yeah you know I can kind of see it a
little bit and they're like yeah you
know you sound white on the phone it's
like yeah I believe it okay cool
makes a little quarter yeah so you
enjoyed a little bit more privilege for
like 30 years yeah and then uh on my on
my wedding day I had to apologize to
everybody's like everybody I'm so sorry
I'm not a quarter White
[Laughter]
yeah they uh but yeah my mom's last name
is skulls and my dad's last name is Dane
put together so it's me because she so
her stepdad is white yeah so I guess she
was adopted by my white grandpa did she
know yeah she everybody else knew just
now everyone except me and that's the
intro to today's off the Record welcome
back y'all we got a great episode of the
careful boys today featuring zero
percent white Ron skulls dang let's give
it up y'all
[Applause]
another white free episode oh man no
Steve no Steve it's white free today
school like growing up as a kid you'd be
like yo I'm a quarter white because you
had a grandfather it gets a little bit
weird yeah I thought it was a quarter
white but throughout School my last name
got changed around because for whatever
reason so I'd be Ron schools Ron dang
Ron Deng schools and then even one of my
fights they they announced me as Ron
dencoles I was like
to the ring I was like oh snap it sounds
kind of cool
how did it get mixed up I have no idea
like even elementary school high school
because you're her mom and dad's legal
name is skullsdang too no just uh just
just me my sister and then my wifey and
then now my kid yeah why just how come
just you and
you don't have that because one of them
is skulls and one of them is dang and
they created school's thing they did it
wrong yeah that was the first so wait oh
so they didn't have it they didn't they
didn't keep the name they kept their own
names why did they do it just for you
well they came up with your sister they
couldn't decide which last name to give
me so they just combined it that's what
I was told they don't want to do the
traditional just go with the dad's name
yeah I didn't even know you could do
that
I thought they got married and then they
decided let's just create a new last
name which they did right oh just for me
yeah see that's what I'm saying is they
didn't keep that because I'm wondering
how difficult it was when you went to
the hospital and they're like yeah you
have to prove that you're the parents
and like no look but your last names
don't match
look at me that's why in school you're
you're getting your name tossed around
somebody because somebody who had to
sign your permission slip maybe it's
somebody scolds one day and another
another day of somebody dang mom or my
dad yeah you know yeah because it wasn't
the same thing that makes sense yeah ask
your parents and your dad's like hey I
[ __ ] up my [ __ ]
well not too hot we put together it's so
confusing man
[Laughter]
say I think it's so easy every time you
[ __ ] up you go dying man
dang it man does that mean your mom's
Vietnamese but had a white uh stepfather
basically yes yeah that's exactly what
if she's full full business she's
totally Asian yeah I assumed she was
half white even though she looked
totally Asian because my grandpa was
white
and then turns out she's just totally
Asian as am I wow
kid's last name that has nothing to do
with yours too
like a ding dong ding dong I know I
should have given like a complete like
freaking Renzo Liu Kang or something oh
[ __ ]
Renzo Liu Kane that came out hella fast
yeah
skull thing is a pretty [ __ ] school
say it's cool yeah what's your wifey's
maiden name
avalara
no we have some weird names like uh we
so one of our names combined would be uh
um
apron but then I came up with rape roll
but it did it good month and
sex offender History Month
who's against rape roll okay everybody
World her mom not the rapist I'll tell
you that it's like either that or apron
yeah April's pretty fired so we kept
apron and then you know our logo is an
apron you know so marketable for April
what would the other logo be
laughs
something important something forceful
too aggressive but what's in the name
right how many kids you have uh one one
kid just one is that the are you working
on more we we have we have plans of
doing like a team of four whoa nice a
team I love it when you
uh it became like a fighting father did
it change
how you acted in The Ring versus a
single man that is like don't have to
worry about babies babies no yeah
nothing's changed I still hit people as
hard as I can
Warrior right there but what about for
your own like you know like do you ever
go like oh [ __ ] what if I get hurt and I
can't be around
don't be so naked negative let's ruin
his fighting he's always thinking about
winning huh and I've been I've been
really fortunate I've been I've been
hurt during a fight once like when I got
a concussion that one time
um oh that was crazy only once yeah that
was it you know for 20 years not bad but
I always told myself I've ever got a
concussion I would quit and then I
recovered from I was like it wasn't that
bad from the weeks of haze that you were
experiencing yeah six six months oh six
months you got six months of haze and
you're like that wasn't that bad yeah
considering yeah I mean I could have
died you know I guess I'm being a [ __ ]
doesn't that make you go what if what if
I'm I'm not around or I'm not the same
like Pops I could be to my kid I I feel
like fighting isn't as dangerous as it
seems like uh like don't let me fight
but they won't let me ride a motorcycle
no it's like oh and I love motorcycles
are you gonna go skydiving yeah yeah
they let me I just uh we haven't had
time when you say you mean your family
yeah yeah okay I thought you talk about
management yeah oh no they let me do it
everything maybe you just thought you
were skydiving because of the haze oh
God skydiving for six months
what's up what's your what's your
fighting record
um for Muay Thai is
so now it's four and one dude Ron's a
[ __ ] killer bro tell me about it tell
me about it I've seen Ron sleep a lot of
people on the internet teammates do
teammates like one of our chairs
teammates that we thought was Unk owable
and Ron put him to sleep twice during
just during uh sparring no through like
he fought him like I knew about like a
hotel I knew about Ron before I even met
run I was like oh that guy is he was
just on the circuit and then I found out
he was training with Bart and I was like
oh [ __ ] it's crazy but yeah dude I train
him yeah you train him my bad sorry my
mistake but Ron just had a fight for a
title we're like basically Brothers we
have the same tattoo artist and I'm I'm
a quarter white see you are oh wait what
like a real for real seven years ago I
stopped believing this I love you too I
know
twinsies but Ron just had a fight for a
championship belt in Muay Thai he got
robbed of okay he got [ __ ] robbed
this is just we're on the streets
watch the video Rod's whooping his ass
you watched I was trying to see I asked
him today if we could find the full
fight where we couldn't but Ron looked
like he was beating this [ __ ] of this
guy and this guy that he fought was a
really very very tough bigger opponent
and a lot of the people say that Ron won
and I'm assuming it was a technical win
because it had to be by decision right
so then like did they ever explain after
they don't why the judges just told me
what do you say so the refs everybody
the corners the promoters like oh dude
we thought you had this and the one of
the judge is like you know this is a uh
kickboxing match you should have kicked
more I was like
what the [ __ ] like what you get off
technical points for not kicking enough
right it was not a preference yeah I was
like what was he Thai uh no
today's video is brought to you by
DraftKings football fans first Sunday of
NFL season is here and DraftKings sports
book an official sports betting partner
of the NFL is giving new customers a
can't miss offer to celebrate the return
of the NFL season right now new
customers can just bet five dollars and
get two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly and as an added bonus for week
one everyone can experience the thrill
of DraftKings early win promotion it's
sample bet on an NFL team to win if your
team leads by 10 at any point during the
game you get paid instantly even if your
team loses download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now and use the promo
code off the Record to get 200 and free
bets instantly when you place a five
dollar bet this Sunday that's called off
the Record only at DraftKings Sportsbook
an official sports betting partner of
the NFL minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details my grandpa says otherwise I get
scored on how much volume you throw
though right and how much yeah a punch a
kick Indian elbow is all a point so I
landed a billion punches but uh I didn't
throw enough kicks so you technically
had more points than him but because you
didn't have kicks they gave it to him as
a winner yes well the other guy that's
one one judge so the other guy sustained
more damage oh yeah I have to but then
there are different rule sets right like
I think like Dutch kick boxing they
score punches and kicks the same in
Thailand kicks or more so you'll see way
more kicking in Thailand so they have
different rule sets and then it changes
the way they fight I don't know what the
rules that they told yeah apparently
this promotion I never thought this uh
not the promotion the organizing body or
whatever yeah I guess
I assume they're really big on kicks but
you're a whooping his ass regardless of
what the [ __ ] you're doing there was a
video that Ron posted and it's like a
highlight of him in this fight and every
time he landed
just the sweat just kept getting
destroyed off this guy's head like pops
just sweat I got a [ __ ] Rocky movie
dude it was crazy it was surreal in the
moment because uh
it was
I wasn't usually I have tunnel vision
but this one it was kind of like I felt
like it was just like a fun sparring
match
um but I saw it like when I hit him I
literally saw the the beads of sweat
come off his face and like splash the
Splash Zone like in the front row I was
like I was like dude there's like the
movies it was very dramatic or the
movies is like what you're doing what do
you what do you mean you usually have
tunnel vision
um well usually I'm uh I have I have no
thoughts I'm just like blank and then
and then uh I just listen to my Corners
I don't even hear usually the fights end
sooner
um this time it didn't went all five
rounds so if you actually had a knockout
then it's undeniably your win even if
you didn't even throw a kick yeah and we
kind of knew that coming in I mean this
this was this is not our home turf this
isn't the promotion that we fight with
these are our people you know uh we knew
if we did not come out there's a good
chance we're gonna lose so if so if you
just put shoes on your hands you would
have probably won
[ __ ] well the other thing I didn't know
either is uh they made us wear uh was it
10 ounce gloves also it's heavier yeah
and squishier so usually I find eight
ounce gloves but I didn't know when you
move up to 147 they give you tens really
yeah because it's too big now yeah I'm a
big strong man so you can't really like
hit them as hard as you usually want to
I mean I hit him as hard as I could but
he took he's just no he could just take
a punch dude I hit him oh a lot but it's
like uh eight ounces it hurts a whole
lot more what do you usually fight at
we're on for a more time 135 so he went
up to 147. damn to fight at the higher
weight class that was so squishy dude
you got rubbed dude it was bad it looked
like they pulled me out of the crowd I
didn't think so I didn't think you
looked very famous
dude you look him in me dude he's
shredded I looked like a doughboy so
this guy's probably like a 160 or 70
drop down probably he was a giant
Russian he's tall as [ __ ] too he's
really good too and then the fact that
Ron just [ __ ] went out there and put
it on him how tall is he
six feet so then you're like five seven
yeah sometimes dude and they oh my God
that is a Rob
so he had reach he had weight he had all
that advantage and you still whooped his
ass
but he also walked home with 10 grand
[Laughter]
yeah it's okay it's uh
my uh my mom is super into uh what's it
called horoscopes and stuff like that
yeah and uh she's been calling my life
like did she say you're gonna lose this
[ __ ] yeah really yeah it was that too
before no oh she like called my left
she's like you're gonna have a hard year
you're gonna work a lot of money's gonna
come in but even more money is going to
come out I was like nice thanks Mom oh
yeah thanks um and then this fight
actually lied to you by your grandpa too
your mom's not a good person hear this
Mom yeah she's kidding he's kidding
but no afterwards she's like hey so what
happens like oh I lost like I knew
you're gonna lose oh come on she's like
oh because uh I went and got your
fortune told but I didn't want to tell
you I didn't want to I didn't want to
hurt your feelings and so go some get
something productive told tell me if the
Lakers are going to win so I can bet the
right way I'll ask her next time I could
have just bet against you and gave you
money yeah I know this should have made
money yeah that's the number one rule
about fortune telling you can't bet
against it really yeah it doesn't work I
made that up oh
there's a number one rule wait wasn't
there a rule like in fortune telling
that you can't do it for money
or the spirits get mad at you something
like that right that you gotta do it
it's gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] up I feel like I've
heard that before you gotta do it for
the purpose of [ __ ] doing it can't
get the genie out the lamp and which to
bring somebody back to life these are
all known rules guys cash for more
wishes and [ __ ] yeah can I ask for more
wishes I don't know these rules there's
Rules to This flush I'm just scared of
it in general I'm like dude I don't want
to know hey do you have do you have a
fight coming up
um I'm supposed to be fighting in
October so I'm either going to defend
you better be made of legs for this one
or yeah he throws nothing but kicks yeah
I've been throwing nothing but kicks and
stuff I do that guys like no it's kick
boxing yeah
it's like I want to see some boxes yeah
no it's too much kicking okay
that's so stupid that's a sucky thing to
say but how does your opponent like feel
about it you know what I mean like is
there like a Fighter's Integrity like is
he like honestly I was getting my ass
whooped I don't know why I won like is
there anything like that I think he has
10 G's so he's like yeah whatever yeah
it is what it is right coffee at least
10 grand dude he I don't think he I
don't think he cares like which is a lot
of money from Muay Thai yeah like
usually you know make like a few
thousand bucks like two three thousand
bucks maybe uh for a purse you know if
you're lucky
um so like to hear 10 grand for Muay
Thai it's a lot of money is there
anything to you just being like hey
rematch uh no not really uh he's not
even my weight class
I have no intentions of fighting in 147.
oh so you just jumped up just because it
was a good like money maker for money I
literally did this like I love Muay Thai
I love fighting I literally did this for
money oh the love of fighting too like
to fight someone bigger and stronger
than you yeah you know like hey how
would I do and then I was like you know
I did pretty good sounds like you did
[ __ ] how come the purse was so much
more for this one is it's a special
promotion or something this is a special
like four-man tournament so like four
people were gonna fight and then there
was gonna be one winner in that night
four guys are gonna fight each other at
once like
I wish that would be so sick I'll just
Royal Rumble that yeah oh my gosh do I
see Russia right now they're doing like
600 yeah
dude if we can coordinate something like
that that would be so amazing I thought
they're at War what the [ __ ] they kind
of are they could just go out and fight
like that how come only some of how come
only some of them had headgear too did
you see that it's just
divers get to go to actual War have you
seen um three Hooligans Hooligans
Hooligans yeah when they meet up and
just start [ __ ] yeah like 50 I think
just throw fire bombs and [ __ ] that's
crazy I've seen some weird stuff do you
see the the arm wrestling fighting the
arm wrestling yeah where they have to
hold
shocking each other that's just [ __ ]
bananas though it's great you wouldn't
do that
no I suck it off recipe that's the arm
wrestling that's just holding on no
because if you get their hand down you
win really yeah you can you distract
them by hitting them in the face
stuck together
you're like
so you're like distracting them
there's different versions because they
have like a hundred variations of all
that [ __ ] they have like the phone booth
ones
the phone book they have phone booth
like boxing and they have like phone
booth Jiu Jitsu I don't know how that is
a photo booth one where it's constantly
taking pictures
yeah
would you do the Russian slap one oh
great oh dude because that's a direct
shot to the jaw yeah you just take it
you just stand there it doesn't seem
like there's weight classes either no
right with like the guy with the albino
guy yeah it's it's tough man because
like most people don't think a slap
hurts but if you slap him with a pull
with the freaking with the pec deck this
you'll knock somebody out with this I
mean this is this is a self-defense
weapon right here and some of these guys
are getting knocked out getting hit just
with that like it's getting clubbed in
the face on purpose and they have to
like piece of bone
but you can't tense up too hard or
you're like kind of getting hit in your
mouthpiece they're not even wearing a
mouthpiece for this they have chalk
though that's good oh yeah for more grip
what's the chalk for would you call this
baby I thought that was baby powder
would you do it for a foreign
eating contest is just as good
they rarely have 20K bags for donuts
unfortunately your competition comes
with a donut yeah if you finish it you
get a free meal every food challenge
I've done I've had to pay for it and
then I've also lost them you never win
the food challenges I'm like oh and two
those big Ramen ones yeah I did a in La
there's a restaurant called origin they
have the spiciest oh right I ate that I
got up to two spoonfuls of soup left and
then I ran to the bathroom threw up oh
no I couldn't finish the soup and it's
like it was like temperature hot it was
just so spicy I couldn't when it when
the when I touched my tongue it felt
like freaking it was like golden Flames
oh I didn't feel when you threw up oh it
was bad they were so mad at me the
people at the restaurant really yeah
because it was everywhere so I was like
a little bit in the bathroom yeah I
expect though it's like a gallon of
[ __ ] soup yeah
a lot of people throw up for me did you
take a spicy dump that night too uh it
was like for four or five days and then
I took a spice I took spicy pukes on the
way home like I had it they had us pull
over and then sometimes I couldn't hold
it stick my hand out the window
oh I think I got poisoned I've had hot
stuff before but like that one's crazy I
feel like that happens to most people
when they do those challenges right yeah
yeah well it wasn't even the hottest
thing I've ever done but it was the
hardest one I've done would you rather
get another concussion or do that again
do that again I never want a concussion
again six months of haze dude it's gonna
be longer too next time you get it it's
not that bad for a concussion six six
months of haze or six months of spicy
throw up dump life oh my God spicy throw
up dump life whoa so eat I can still
function I can still work and focus
um because I was like all right back to
work you know but with Daisy I'm just
like oh whole time maybe that's why your
name got [ __ ] up you just wouldn't
went hazy and wrote it wrong all these
times yeah right
[Laughter]
[Music]